so back at the beginning of february
2019 dj marshmallow performed a
live concert inside epic games online
gaming sensation
fortnite and i have since then been
informed via numerous breathy think
pieces that fortnite is no longer merely
a game but is now a
content delivery platform experience
and so logically the only sensible thing
for me to do
is to get in on this and pivot entirely
to fortnite
welcome to the brand new folding ideas
all fortnight digital studio that is not
only a digital studio because i'm
producing digital content but
it is also literally a digital studio
it is double digital and
this this arm waving emote is the only
meaningful animation i've got and
there's nothing available that really
looks like talking so
i i guess it's what i'm going with for
now so when you see me doing this
it it means i'm talking to you
it took me like 20 hours to unlock this
fortnite developed by epic games is an
online four-player cooperative base
building
tower defense shooter game released as
early access with in-game purchases in
july 2017
the game has been utterly eclipsed by
its free to play subgame
fortnite battle royale launched in
september 2017.
battle royale a format popularized by
playerunknown's battlegrounds and
originally inspired by the 2000 japanese
horror film battle royale
is a last player standing free-for-all
where 100 players are dropped onto an
island with an ever-shrinking zone of
engagement and left to scrounge
resources
build defenses and fight until only one
remains
in the wake of the success of fortnite
battle royale the original fortnight has
been renamed
fortnite save the world a critical bit
of fortnite's development
comes from the involvement of chinese
multimedia firm tencent
in 2012 epic games approached 10 cent
for help with the then fledgling
fortnight seeking their input on turning
the game into a live
service platform meaning it would
function as an
ongoing revenue stream rather than
simply being a single purchase
product tencent agreed to help and
supply additional financial resources
and expertise
in exchange for being allowed to
purchase a 40
stake in the company an arrangement to
which epic agreed
following the merger a number of
high-profile staff retired from epic
including cliff blezinski adrian
chamelars lee perry and rod ferguson
all to one degree or another citing
dissatisfaction with either the 10 cent
merger
the games as a service business model or
both
but that's not what you're here for
you don't want a history lesson placing
fortnite into an appropriate cultural
context
you're here for hot fortnite player
on player action uh it's player versus
player
wait what did i say
[Music]
so remember to follow me on twitch tv i
kill weed names because you can enjoy
what the earth mother gave us but that
isn't the same
as having a personality
one of the things in particular that
stands out to me about the metanarrative
surrounding fortnite
[Music]
hey isn't it weird how hostile the
free-to-play track is
like it's not simply structured to drive
paying for something or another it
actually starts
[Music]
okay so what's all this about a concert
in fortnite
on february 2nd 2019 christopher
comstock who performs under the dj name
marshmallow
played a 10-minute concert in fortnite's
pleasant park
my name is marshmallow and thank you for
coming out today and making history with
me you guys ready
[Music]
or more accurately at 2pm eastern time
players who joined a special marshmallow
concert game mode got to watch a
scripted concert event during which
weapons and damage were deactivated to
ensure that players couldn't be grieved
and that the event wouldn't be
interrupted with gunfire and explosions
it's maybe a bit of a pointless hair to
split the fact that the concert was
pre-recorded and not actually live
but i mean that's what we do here we
deconstruct narratives and the idea
that this was a live set was very much
part of the narrative
the fiction extended to the fact that
the mini set was
added to marshmallow's tour schedule a
significant component of the implicit
messaging was to demonstrate the
flexibility of fortnite the
concept of fortnite as a content
delivery platform
as a scripted event utilizing the game's
engine
server architecture and assets the
concert is quite impressive
the crowd does end up looking a little
thin because it turns out 60 people per
match just
isn't that many if you're trying to
simulate an actual audience
but players maneuvering virtual bodies
need a bit more space to do things than
real people
and keeping the population low mitigated
problems with players who are
accessing on lower end hardware internet
connections
minimizing the odds that they would lag
out or just
crash entirely
as a delivery platform however well
it demonstrates the flexibility and
possibilities that fortnite
offers if you're dj marshmallow
the concert isn't actually built in
fortnite it's full of bespoke assets and
scripting that could only be constructed
with the active participation of epic
games
while fortnite has a creative mode that
allows players to build their own spaces
even very impressive spaces nothing like
this is remotely doable while it's
possible to put on a concert in fortnite
it's not possible for
you to put on a concert in fortnite
the actual audience for this specific
message is big name collaborators epic
is advertising the idea
that fortnite is a viable venue for
crossover promotional opportunities
this is all part of the concept of games
as a live
service so we should probably spend some
time disassembling that particular
narrative concept
fortnite isn't really a game like
there's a game attached to fortnite but
that's not the core
of fortnite fortnite is first and
foremost
a storefront the monetization systems in
fortnite battle royale are seemingly
simple on their face
but well join me on a journey the two
arms of fortnite's monetization are the
battle pass and the item shop
both of which are fueled by an in-game
token currency called
v-bucks v-bucks are used here as in most
other micro-transaction-based games as a
means to bypass financial regulations
involving held value
and some regional laws surrounding
gambling with regards to the loot crates
because in many regions it doesn't count
as gambling if the currency evolved is
non-fungible
basically in a lot of places it doesn't
legally count as
gambling if you're gambling with fun
bucks that can't be converted back into
legal tender so things that utilize all
the structure vocabulary and
psychological mechanisms of gambling
like video game loop crates or gachapon
toys
aren't technically gambling as far as
the law is concerned
because you can't convert your winnings
directly back into dollars
additionally the use of v-bucks also
allows epic to obfuscate the assigned
value of both
in-game purchases and the value of
v-bucks themselves
by giving buyers a bulk discount for
buying more and handing out v bucks for
performing in-game activities
nominally one v-buck is worth just under
one us
cent but if you buy 10 000 v-bucks at a
cost of 99.99 us
you get an air quote bonus 3500
so the actual monetary cost of anything
you buy on the store varies by about 25
depending on how many v bucks you bought
if you're confused
that's the point the primary utility of
funny money is to relieve you of the
pressure in weighing
if this specific skin is worth 15
or is it 11 this is on top of another
really common strategy where the amounts
don't scale evenly and don't
line up cleanly with the cost of actual
items
increasing the likelihood that you'll
always have some left over
or will need to buy a substantial amount
in order to get the thing that you want
this particular bit is pretty common but
fortnite manages to take it to a whole
new level
this is ultimately the meaning of game
as a service
it's just a euphemism for a game that
takes up all your free time and becomes
the only game that you play
because it's just an elaborate
constantly resetting skinner box that
utilizes progression systems and
seasonal competition
as a means to place you constantly in
the path of an endless stream of
monetary interactions
to top it off as a game fortnite battle
royale
isn't even particularly great the
matchmaker is utterly bare bones and
pays no regard to your performance so
you'll almost always be matched with a
mix of players who are
barely functional and several who are so
far above your skill level that
you're not even really playing the same
game the building mechanics in battle
royale are unwieldy and create a
tremendous skill gap that contributes to
the aforementioned disparity
but they're also the whole gimmick that
the game is built around so
that's kind of take it or leave it the
game is full of weird unpolished edge
cases like vehicles all using slightly
different control schemes even for
shared functionality
you get on a hoverboard and the speed
boost is bound to left shift but on a
quad crasher
boost is spacebar even though left shift
isn't bound to anything on the quad
crasher
because of the way that systems interact
in particular the ways that the building
mechanics are vital for defending
against long range attacks but
are also so effective for either closing
distance or escaping
that the mid-range effectively barely
exists
the game biases extremely heavily
towards shotguns
basically becoming a contest of closing
distance and gaining height so you can
land a shotgun headshot on your
opponents
if you strip out everything else the
game is a moderately okay shooter with a
unique twist and a compelling aesthetic
it's not
dire but it's kind of just barely good
enough to stand on its own without the
rest of the hooks
and oh boy does fortnite have hooks
the item shop is pretty grotesque when
you break down its underlying mechanics
in contrast to pretty much every other
game on the market fortnite only
displays
10 to 13 items at a time rotating on a
daily basis
this has the dual purpose of obfuscating
what's available
and creating a fomo response or fear of
missing out
if you see something you like you have a
limited window in which to purchase it
and with the total
inventory of products obfuscated there's
no sense of how long
it might be until that particular item
is available again
or even if it will ever be available
again
at all incidentally alfonso ribeiro
isn't just suing epic because his
carlton dance made it into the game but
because they took his work and were
selling it for eight bucks a pop
the other arm of the monetization system
is the battle pass which costs a little
under 10
u.s and ties into the seasonal
progression track system
which is itself broken into two tiers
freed and paid
for tonight's cyclical gameplay is
broken up into 10 week seasons and the
battle pass applies only for a given
season
the paid track just throws piles of
stuff at you every tier to incentivize
playing more
including an early perk of an experience
boost next
season just in case you were maybe
considering not getting the next battle
pass 10 weeks from now
what's interesting about the free track
is that it doesn't merely make use of
fomo
psychology it's not just saying oh look
at all this stuff you'd get if you
bought the battle pass
though i mean it is literally saying
that right there
but in addition to that it's making use
of
hostile design the free track actually
ends at tier 62 though the season track
goes until 100
there's no additional free rewards past
this point
from here it's not simply a matter of a
fear of missing out the entire battle
pass system is founded on the dopamine
rush of unlocking something new
every few hours of play to keep players
coming back
within that context the point where the
game stops giving you stuff entirely
the game is withdrawing the thing that
is used to get you hooked
it is punishing you for having dared
play this long
without paying this is manufactured
discontent and make no mistake you will
have to play
a lot to get to this point again with
the layers of deliberate obfuscation the
broad progression systems are broken
into
two parts first account level which is
itself broken into total level and
seasonal level
and the battle pass which we've
discussed progressing
in level is done by earning experience
which is rewarded at the end of every
match
while progressing the battle pass is
done by earning battle stars
battle stars are rewarded in amounts
ranging from 2 to 10
for every level and for completing
challenges which come in daily and
weekly flavors
daily challenges tend to be fairly
straightforward ranging from placing in
the top 25
to scoring a number of takedowns with a
specific weapon type
while weekly challenges tend to get more
varied and abstract and include things
like visiting specific locations on the
map
now briefly i want to touch on the
psychological design elements of the
weekly challenges and the way that
they're presented
first there's the element of fomo in the
completion reward of 5000 xp
a substantial amount of experience
requires completing
four challenges but only three are
available for free
second the paid battle pass challenges
aren't simply locked but are turned into
a mystery box
if you don't pay you don't even get to
see what they
are tantalizing isn't it
you only need one more you're
so close let's go back to these tracks
they're presented as roughly analogous
literally
in parallel but progression along these
tracks aren't even
the gold tier players have access to
more challenges which reward
more battle stars which in turn reward
direct experience
on top of experience multipliers gold
players don't just
get more they get it faster and with
less effort
so this point tier 62 it's highly
unlikely that you'll actually get to
this point without playing
a lot of fortnite every single day
i've actually needed to play a lot of
fortnite pretty much every day in the
course of making this video
both in order to ensure i understood the
game itself well enough to speak about
it confidently
and also just to get the specific kinds
of footage i was looking for
and at the midpoint of season eight
i'm less than halfway there this maybe
seems like i'm just complaining about
the free-to-play players not getting
enough stuff
but that's not actually the point the
underlying purpose of demonstrating all
this
is to show the mechanisms that the
creators are willing to employ these
psychological tricks
are in effect a form of rhetoric a form
of persuasive speech
they are trying to persuade you by
applying select forms of pressure
and it is i think worth understanding
the mechanisms of that pressure so that
we can better recognize
how and when we are being persuaded
also it's worth keeping in mind that as
a season is only 10 weeks long
a paid player can slip back into being a
free player at any time in order to
retain all the perks of
being a paid player one would need to
buy
all four to five season passes
every year all of this goes hand in hand
the marshmallow concert isn't a thing
happening in parallel to the
monetization systems
it's a core pillar the external purpose
of things like this are fairly
straightforward it's a publicity stunt
an oddity that people will talk about
the cost of assembling the technical
aspects of the concert and paying
comstock for his participation
were effectively weighted against a
direct ad buy and
based on the coverage epic tencent is
probably pretty happy with the outcome
the internal purpose is a little more
arcane and i wouldn't blame you if you
wanted to use the word
sinister the purpose of the concert is
to utilize the social pressure of
exclusion let's take a closer look at a
couple key moments
let me see everybody doing that
marshwalk right now let me see that
marshwood
find your squad and let me see your
favorite let me see what you've got
let's go
all right i want to see everybody doing
their favorite right now
if marshmallow is calling out for you to
use your favorite emote well
if you haven't paid in odds are you
don't
have any or the ones you do have are
going to be pretty
generic and lame events like the concert
create environments where the ability to
self-express is placed at a premium
in order to feel like a full and active
participant
you need to be able to perform the catch
is that literally every unique action
has an attached price tag let me see
everybody doing that
right now and there are some things
that you'll simply never get without
paying players who haven't bought a skin
don't even have control over their basic
image there
isn't a roster of default looks to
choose from
your look is assigned randomly after
every match
there isn't just a layer of fomo the
sense
that others around you with cooler more
expressive character models are having
more fun
are better able to project themselves
into the social space
there's a level of hostility in the
design
if you don't buy in you aren't merely
limited in your options of expression
you are actively denied control over the
most
basic element of how you choose to look
in the virtual world
nothing that fortnite does is
particularly new
these complex monetization systems with
multiple layers of obfuscation
you can find this in pretty much any
mobile game
and plenty of desktop and console games
are laden with cosmetic micro
transactions
legally dubious gambling and other ways
to aggressively monetize the game
lots of games use progression systems
and incremental rewards as part of their
core loop to keep players playing
fortnite is really just a maturation of
those systems
a refinement of every habit-forming
trick and micro-transaction
pressure point developed in the last
decade condensed
into a weaponized product targeted at
kids
one of the articles that originally
called my attention to all of this
was one nick stat wrote for the verge
titled fortnite's marshmallow concert
was a bizarre and exciting glimpse of
the future
i disagree with nick's breathy
excitement
but on the whole he's right fortnite is
a glimpse of the future
an awful perpetually monetized
vertically integrated
vaguely hostile future
you